you
how everyone's cheery about chess keep
gonna play a five-minute game okay we
have a ace rook 25:21 okay let's see
what we have
ooh the birds opening Oh try if i do ii
5 there's that gambit d6 that white does
well to avoid i don't know if i should
try that because I think I like the
white position if white just goes ahead
and declines that to kind of just get a
half-open f5 for nothing so let's go
with just a classical style chest
establish a pun in the center so let's
actually go with this right now I'm
anticipating that a white was going to
go with them some control over ee5 so
that's why i want to get my bishop on
this dogma before they could and now
with this movie for so that weakens this
square right away and I just want to
basically put all my pieces there so I'm
tempted to just do Bishop to f5 right
now and that's what I'm going to go for
so I'm perfectly fine with the light
square bishop exchange doubled pawns
aren't really a big deal because that's
just going to help out in the control
over that efore point so half open file
is this really going to turn out to be
something that's a drawback I don't I
don't know about that so in the meantime
Knight d7 mm 97 or c6 I'm gonna go to d7
just to allow this seep on some
possibilities I want to go c6 or c5 I'm
not quite sure and castle not going to
castle it just yet I want to see what
this Knight wants to do first also what
was also I was also considering this e 6
move but I didn't like that Bishop 8 3
move stopping me from King side castling
so I guess capture hmm which direction
I'm going to capture towards the center
and I wonder if I could try and oh I was
not expecting that
okay so I have to I have to be concerned
about a queen maybe coming out here if I
play I play h6 first hmm there any
tricks with Queen coming out Knight here
type of moves takes Queen h5 not really
singing let's just get that guy out of
there it's kind of bugging me though
what is going on with this move wow
that's there's no there's not gonna be
compensation for that is there oh oh
well actually there is isn't there all
right I gotta hang on to this upon right
here I'm gonna lose I'm losing three
pawns right now mm-hmm
so how can I fight back here so alright
let's try what an interesting inbounds
right here offer a queen extreme Queen
exchange three pawns for the minor piece
and actually I'm giving up another pawn
apparently I really don't care about my
pawns of this game oh man there goes an
oh well I wasn't that was that could
have been a fourth pawn but instead just
running with this okay well let's try
here in case this move comes I could
have a support point and I don't know
about that particular move let's let's
place this pawn here and actually I
should have maybe given more weight to
this particular move if I could maintain
my knight right here I think I'm going
to be in pretty good shape I did this
move not only to go and cover this
square but to get my Bishop eventually
around in this direction but I think I
want to take into account this advance
as well so my king I want to get it
centralized and I guess I'm gonna have
to be content with going here my
opponent really should capture that
otherwise Knight d3 is going to be a
beast
so King e 7 if this pawn pushes and I'm
gonna lock down on this this is a
potential target so where should I be
going here actually I'm going to go here
and get ready to meet this pond
push with this that's my that's my big
plan however you know it might even be
better than that right here my my rook
is guarding a ton of lateral squares in
this rook is going to be pinpointing
this guy and I think I need some more
support for this I want to control all
potential pawn breaks get my rook
finally doing something other than
functioning along a file and tie down
one of these rooks so where do I make
progress that King went on quite a
journey right there okay two minutes to
318 how do I break through here hmm well
there's maybe even potential for bet
back rank mates my bishop maybe control
that h2 square I'm gonna run with all
run with this no no no no that was just
mouse slipped right there let's not
mouse slip okay let's back up and go
here I'm getting ready to I'm prepping
c5 this is my big plan at this point c5
coming up and my opponent does I think I
don't know that that's a good plan now I
have a past beep on this is going to
translate into a past beep on and his
King is not even close to being able to
stop well actually no I'm just this is a
clear win now yeah this is gonna be a
win because I have a pass to beep on
right now so I'm not sure if that King
Run was a good idea there but um yeah
I'm gonna be picking off this guy I was
down potentially four pawns earlier but
I don't know what is what is all white
do here I don't have any any good
suggestions it's just going to be me
crashing through on the D file and
pushing this C pawn and this B punt is
very fast now these past pawns that
white have white has connected past
pawns and they're not really usually
they're a good thing but not in this
particular endgame especially this King
just being in the corner I'm not really
seeing what Y could be doing here where
the rook has to go somewhere off of the
D file
and we're just gonna have resignation
here what is going on
did my opponent log off two minutes
three seconds what would you do here as
white this it's almost like a two-to-one
majority right here just considering the
B and C files so I guess I could be
doing c4 and then b3 that was a really
interesting sack I didn't really I
thought I was just going to be losing
two pawns but um okay let's just crash
through so it's going to be a much more
simplified position and I think I just
pushed right away
actually here it is this idea that I was
referring to earlier with my bishop
being able to control this Square it's
showing itself right now in fact this is
the most direct move after the King goes
to e5 but when I came here my first
thought was actually Bishop to e1 and
then g3 but actually just Bishop to e5
would have finished off white very
quickly but there was a pretty
interesting game again that efore Square
as soon as that as soon as my opponent
plays that e-excuse me that d4 move
right here that that translates into a
plan for me so I was just trying to get
all my pieces focused on this Square and
keep my keep my C pawn have it some
movement and then really interesting
sack right here I thought I think I'm
white could just go ahead and take that
C pawn I'm not sure maybe thinking that
eventually I could get a rook and then I
get this white C pawn right there in
return but interesting imbalance right
here I'm not sure of the a pawn push
because of the pivot
I would be tempted maybe to play a three
and then c4 and I think without my
knight having a good home I think I
might be in some really tough shape
right there but anyhow I was able to
lock down on the position and carry
through with a plan right there the c5
pawn break so that's all for this video
as always I hope you got something out
of it take care bye